the jogan experience all these things
get corrupted and
particularly today we just um you know
the size of the US federal government is
it's the biggest organization in the
history of the world it's there's
nothing there's not even a close second
and it's uh got survival instincts yeah
it doesn't want to give up ground it
doesn't want to give up power it wants
to keep expanding it wants more funding
for its projects it wants to hire more
people to deal with something in an
incompetent way and it's not like the
free market where it like if it's
incompetent like there's going to be a
competitor that comes along does a
better job and you're going to lose the
market well you ever look at the um if
you look at like the uh the list of the
richest counties in in America and
they're like I forget the exact numbers
it's like it's all obvious it's like 10
of the they're all not all but the vast
majority of them are right outside
Washington DC and right outside New York
City and so like what is that this is
that is that capitalism do you go to
Washington DC and you go oh there's all
there's more millionaires there than
there are in any other part of the world
in the suburbs around Washington DC is
that because there's great big factories
and they're making so much stuff that
everyone wants to buy it's like no
that's because our centralized federal
government spends over $6 trillion a
year and where does that money go it
goes into all the people who are
connected to government and why is it
outside of New York City is it because
in New York City they have great big
factories where they're making all the
things that everyone wants it's like no
and that's not cuz of capitalism that's
cuz Richard Nixon took us off the gold
standard and now it's just this phony
Casino Wall Street money so it's
everybody all the people at the top who
are making all of this money they're not
making it it'd be one thing if you're um
if you're like uh John D Rockefeller
before he went in colluded with the
government and you're you created
Standard Oil and now there's this big
oil company and you're making the
country richer by this but they're not
making the country richer they're
extracting wealth out of the rest of the
population it's all just extracted out I
mean literally the federal spending is
extracting wealth out of people by
taxing them and then spending it
literally taking the money from people
who work and giving it to politically
connected people and then the the Wall
Street money is just printing money and
then making your dollar less valuable so
just in another way extracting wealth
from the people and this is basically
why we live in this populist moment
right now where so many people are so
freaking furious at The
Establishment because they right to be
they right to be it's a [__] system it's
a [__] scary system that you can never
beat if it gets to make its own rules
well it's not what it and it's not what
America was supposed to be also it's so
wild the stock market is such a wild
idea that it's based on confidence and
you you bet on companies yeah
essentially betting on buying and
selling and you can wreck them and you
can own them and you know and there's
people that just play that game all they
do is like chase after businesses short
businesses you could short a country
yeah yeah yeah yeah no it's it's pretty
wild it's pretty wild and craziest
gambling but this is also you know like
to go back to like Ron Paul stuff this
was like at the center of his campaign I
don't think anybody else um outside of
like the libertarian party will will put
up candidates who like talk about this
stuff but Ron Paul was the only one like
in a major party who got like a huge
amount of traction behind him but where
he was like look this is all like when
you go when you have a fiat currency
system and you go off of any type of
gold or anything that kind of limits the
government's ability to just print as
much money out of thin air as they want
to you get this thing where we live in a
cycle of constant inflation and this is
something that people don't put that
much thought into like you know when
you're talking to your grandma or
something and she's like in my day a
bottle of coke was a nickel we just take
that almost as like yeah well that's how
it works things over time get way more
expensive that's just how cuz cuz that's
been so just how we've always
experienced life that it's just a given
that everything's always going to be be
a little more expensive and we may have
a bad year where things are like 9% more
expensive and then maybe we'll have a
better year where things are only 2%
more expensive but it's always going in
this direction but that's not a law of
nature that doesn't just have to be that
way and in fact if you looked at like
from the year uh say 1800 to the year
1900 somebody talking to their
grandparents would have had the complete
opposite uh thing they would have been
like oh my God it was so much more
expensive when I was young and now
things are getting cheaper and in fact
the natural tendency in a society that's
developing the natural pressure is for
things to get cheaper because if you
just think about it right like you get
more efficient at making them you get
you know what I'm saying like you get
you get more efficient at making them
you can make more things with less
Manpower that would naturally put a
downward pressure on prices but because
the government keeps printing money the
value of the money goes down and so we
live in the system where things get more
and more expensive but then when you
have that right and then you have all
types of government incentives on top of
that right so it's like okay first of
all you're going to if you just hold
your money cuz this is what people used
to do many generations ago was the idea
of just saving your money you save it
but if you just save your money today
Joe you're a sucker because of this
system right like if you just hold your
dollars well you're just losing money
actively so you got to be chasing
interest in order to just not lose money
you have to be chasing an investment you
know what I mean you have to be like
gambling on something and so now and
then of course there's also other like
tax incentives where like you you can
kind of defer taxes if you invest in
things and so you're kind of like pushed
into you know like well put it in your
401k put it in this put it in that and
then you won't but just think about that
like logically aside from being really
good for Rich
Bankers why would you think that it's a
good for like an average you know say
like couple who's just like working and
making money and they don't know
anything about stocks and bonds and
trading for you know Exchange traded
funds and what to invest in and what not
why would you say that you you should be
working no you shouldn't be working in
saving a little bit for your uh for your
retirement what you should be doing is
gambling you should always be gambling
your money constantly isn't that sound
financial advice Gamble and gamble on
something that you don't understand
right and you've done no research on
yeah trust someone who works on Wall
Street do you remember that time about a
year or so ago where Banks started
failing mhm remember that remember
spooky that was yeah where Banks started
going under and there was a real concern
that it would cause a you know a Cascade
effect they were very very concerned
about that yeah and it didn't but it got
close and we had never heard about that
many bank I mean there was a savings and
loan crisis remember when a bunch of
those places went under yeah I remember
that I found out about that because
Vinnie Penza the boxer lost a bunch of
money in one of those oh really yeah
like you know I think his life
earnings I think he lost a shitload of
money like quite a few people have lost
a lot of money in these [__] things
Banks go under all a sudden you lose
everything like what you don't have my
money well and of in in 2008 was that
was the big one you know in 2008 and
they really set a precedent there with
that kind of too big to fail line of
logic where if that's true that the
banks are too big to fail and then you
bailed all of them out and now they're
bigger than they were then then they're
really too big to fail now right so it
kind of perpetuates this idea that we
listen the banking system and everybody
kind of knows this the banking system is
built on a house of cards um and it
could collapse at any moment and if it
does the federal government's going to
have to come rob you of your money to
give to a bunch of Bankers again that's
our system that's our financial system
and the CEOs of those Banks still got
bonuses oh yeah yeah yeah yeah they all
still got bonus said they had to give
them bonuses otherwise they would leave
and go other places and it's and it
shows it shows a real um like eroding of
something completely different than the
political system just our culture that
there wasn't at least like like enough
shame of those people to just go yeah
I'm going to not take my bonus this year
cuz I don't want to get dragged through
the streets and like killed by the
citizens of this country I don't want to
feel like that and it's not as if these
people didn't already have tens of
millions of dollars like they really
needed their bonus from this year or
like little Timmy isn't going to get his
Thanksgiving turkey yeah it's like no I
want a fifth yacht yeah like that level
but the the the whole banking system is
it what's the um oh man I'm gonna get
this what's the Christmas movie where
they kind of go over fractional Reserve
banking uh is it It's a Wonderful Life
or the one where they're like where they
all come into the bank there's like a
bank run and they want their money and
he's like oh but don't you see your
money's over here at Frank's farm and
then his money's over there and that's
how but like uh I I can't remember which
one it was but anyway was that it's a
wonderful life is that what it was yes I
think it was It's a Wonderful Life oh no
maybe not old ass movie no yeah yeah
it's an old one but there go but the
whole system of fractional Reserve
banking is really kind of this
fascinating like thing because everybody
still kind of has in their mind that if
you you kind of have in your mind that
the money in your bank account is your
money and that you're holding it that
they are holding it for you right but
that's not right that's not what's going
on and if you ever actually read like
the contract that you sign when you open
uh a checking account that's not what it
is it's more like you're loaning money
to the bank and they owe that money to
you but they don't have to give it to
you they you could legally speaking you
could walk in tomorrow uh to a bank I
mean no one actually walks up to a
teller anymore it's a wonderful life
isn't a Christmas movie it's a banking
movie oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so that is
the scene I was right about that okay uh
but so you you could walk into the bank
tomorrow and you're checking you know
account balance is whatever say it's
$5,000 and you could go I'd like to take
out $2,000 and they can say no you can't
have it now they owe it to you
technically but they don't have to give
it to you they're not just holding it
for you to give to you on demand now the
system hasn't collapsed so they will
give that to you today if you walk into
a bank but when but if too many people
come in and they want too much money
well they don't have it yeah is the
point so when you open a bank account
and I don't know exactly what the
reserve rates are now because I know
they did change this during Co but for a
while it was 10% um was the what the
Federal Reserve set as the reserve uh
that you had to put away so when you
come into your bank and you give them
$100 to open a checking account just to
make it an easy number they they hold
$10 and they loan out
$90 and now so they they'll loan that
money out and so essentially they owe
you $100 but the the effect of this
right is that now there's this this guy
so let's say you open in the account
with $100 now there's another guy who
takes out a loan for $90 and you're now
in the economy and kind of like you
think you have $100 and he thinks he has
$90 but really there's only there's not
$190 there's only $100 that you get what
I'm saying but now here's where it gets
even crazier than that this guy doesn't
just hold his
$90 he goes and puts it in the
bank and so the bank holds 10% of that
money and then loans out 90% of that to
somebody else who then puts that money
in the bank and then they take 10% of so
when you actually look at the effect of
it there's like not nearly as much money
in the bank as we all think we have in
the world so essentially if everybody
came into the bank or even just too many
people came into the bank and said we'd
like to withdraw our money there's
nowhere near enough money for them to
give you so inherently the whole thing
is kind of a house of cards it's like
when you're going to a stadium and try
to use your cell phone you realize
there's no signal even though you have
five bars because everyone's using their
phone so there's no signal for you you
can't get online you can't make a phone
call right like this thing only works if
we're not all trying to do it at the
same time but if we do then we're in a
lot of trouble
yeah